from danny hey michael i consider myself
a recovering leftist
i was converted to conservatism by my
wonderful husband when you often
describe the crazy purple-haired
feminist
there's me oh hey i'm glad we got a
former
purple-haired feminist to watch the show
i recently posted something about
brianna taylor's case
on social media and my old college
roommate who i haven't seen in years
flat out called me a racist
yeah that's what they do they do that a
lot all because we didn't agree
my position to you is in two parts how
do you handle personal vitriol from
those you may
have once considered friends and how
does it end for america came for ben
stayed for knowles this is a fallen
world evil happens
uh going back to uh what we were
discussing earlier
with regard to the only possibility of
redemption
christ comes into the world and he
doesn't say hey
i'm the way and the truth and the life
and when you proclaim me
and when you are with me then everybody
will be really nice to you he doesn't
does not say that
yeah you'll you'll you'll be treated so
well in this world
he who thrives in this world for my sake
will
keep thriving no doesn't say all of that
people don't like the truth right
you want the truth you can't handle the
truth so
very often people would rather live in
darkness and shadows
and not be in the light and not talk
about the truth and this is just baked
into it
look at what they did to jesus right
just not to put too fine a point on it
but that that actually is an example for
us
that that is what pick up your cross
pick up your cross and bear it right
so obviously we're just talking about a
very narrow example here which is over
some political debates
but it gets to a broader example which
is that very often when you proclaim the
truth you will be persecuted for it
because it's a fallen world that's the
cost of it that's the cost of
preferring the truth to lies that's the
cost of having courage
to being a coward that's the cost of the
virtues
i think the benefits of those virtues uh
certainly outweigh the costs
it's a it's a good investment in the
long run but in the short run
your friends or your former friends are
going to say all sorts of nasty horrible
things about you
that's just the way it is i'll give you
an example of this i
my first political campaign i ever
worked on was for a friend of mine she
was running for congress
in my district i was 18 or 19.
so freshman or sophomore in college
in my hometown i had been the golden boy
my whole life you know
top of the class class president uh
always all the
parents were very nice to me and
everything and uh very sort of
i don't know i was very well liked and
the minute
that i started working for a republican
totally mainstream republican candidate
just as an intern on a campaign
half the town called me all sorts of
horrible things
so wait a second two weeks ago you were
saying i was a nice guy well yeah but
now you're a republican so sorry
sorry you're a terrible racist awful
vicious terrible no good person
comes with the territory comes with the
territory and
dick cheney had a point on this he was
asked does it bother you people call you
darth vader and he said
when i was secretary of defense as the
most popular man in the country 90 plus
percent approval rating
when i was vice president i was one of
the least popular men in the country
if i wanted to be popular i would have
been a movie star sometimes it's more
important to be successful than to be
popular
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you